hello hey um I have to go grab Madison
real quick because she forgot her past
so I'll be right back but sit please
okay whoo brownies oh my god they look
so good and I was like that's not what
it means at all oh I know yeah
these are so good Wow someone listening
to relieve a lot of stress
yeah well Brandis what my favorite thing
ever oh okay
Bridget um those are special brownies
how many have you had
hmm their weed brownies
[ __ ] oh sure no no don't even worry
about it it's gonna be totally fine yeah
I didn't know what it probably didn't
even affect you that much I'm gonna have
one too yeah but you know what I'm only
gonna have half because amazing very
strong yeah um I'll have to though okay
this is gonna be fun yeah yeah yeah
you're right
it's gonna be fine is this my face
where's Madison go I have a thanks
Madison do you have a nice face
I do listening uh hungry you wanna get
some food I can't swallow how do you
follow okay
no you've gotta stay alive for the
chicken tenders there's oh good god oh
my arms do I still have all just so
beautiful Passons
it's home she'd probably have some water
oh hey she's not like that okay yeah hey
ranch anyway okay they only had blue
cheese which is insane that's gonna come
back to haunt you later
why are we even on this planet well
Bridget I'm glad you brought this up
I've been thinking about this a lot and
I feel like the universe is like an
aquarium and we are all the killer
whales so he should probably road trip
across America because that's what makes
no sense in this world
sorry i rambling a lot I just I I really
like talking to you Bridget in fact I
think that I like you more than a friend
and I'm sorry if that's weird but that's
just how I feel
well that's probably for the best
Bridget mm-hmm let's get you home
huh why don't you ban oh I wouldn't like
an ice cream